l'économie toujours avec un marché en
pleine expansion les célibataires dont
le nombre augmente régulièrement c'est
un paradoxe dans un monde où tout le
monde parle de communication les
rencontres n'ont jamais semblé aussi
difficile alors on connaissait les clubs
où les agences matrimoniales mais il ya
plus le speed dating par exemple en bon
français les rendez-vous express c'est
le dossier de cette émission il est
signé sébastien legay et mathieu dreujou
il y à des questions que les
célibataires ont toujours détesté
viendrez-vous accompagné par exemple ce
soir au moins tous les coeurs sont
solitaires c'est le speed dating de
brèves rencontres à la chaîne à chaque
fois sept minutes pour convaincre
cette agence parisienne en organise tous
les soirs les regards sont appuyés les
sourires généreux quand on dépense 35
euros on n'a pas le temps de tourner
autour du pot
on fait des questions
j'ai beaucoup voyagé l' avantage c'est
que tout le monde est là pour la même
chose il ya déjà un point commun après
servez-le fier de voir faire suivant
d'heure alors moi j'ai mon produit c'est
moi pour une fois que j'ai la chance
d'avoir un bon produit devant tous les
célibataires sont à la mode
pourtant ils ne sont pas plus nombreux
qu'avant environ 8 millions au club med
ou conclure est une tradition on tente
d'oublier la fermeture du village yoyo
conçu pour les jeunes fêtards
l'idée reste d'assouplir les horaires
pour capter l'image de liberté associée
au célibat aujourd'hui s'exprime plus
leur différence et c'est vrai qu'ils ont
les attentes différentes
donc faut pouvoir y répondre et c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire autre style de
rencontre dans un resto à sushis ce
n'est pas le bruit qui gêne ici la
drague et silencieuse et high tech du
bout de sa baguette on s'écrit des
messages pour choisir le destinataire le
plan de table est disponible sur
ordinateur
le 9 je sais qu'ici le 11 mai mme
rossetti traitement oui je sais qui
c'est aussi faire une rencontre tout en
gardant ses distances
on ne savait pas que ça pouvait marcher
si pour battre votre coeur a besoin d'un
peu plus de chaleur essayez cette soirée
à montpellier les garçons attendent
derrière le rideau
s'ils sont très chaud ce soir
présentation à l'aveuglette plus ou
moins fleur bleue moi ce que je
recherche c'est une heure une blonde à
forte poitrine
on vous imagine à un voyageur passionné
et on vous attend sur notre rocher une
fois par mois les célibataires de la
région d'in qu'entre pour 40 euros à
l'apéro chacun cherche chaussure à son
pied
boulon à son écrou
la branche zone en deux volets
à chaque table un téléphone et un numéro
pour tenter une approche j'ai pas
spécialement timide mais il ya des
moments où certains prennent au sérieux
cette occasion de se caser
d'autres peu sûrs de leur démarche
relativise l'enjeu
mais bon cela dit je suis là pardon pour
ce sociologue ce nouveau style de
rencontre révèle un individualisme
croissant ces nouveaux célibataires
cherchent l'âme soeur comme ils font
leurs courses derrière quelle idée ya
yal'idée je reste moi-même avec ma vie
telle qu'elle existe actuellement et je
rajoute l'autre en plus donc je ne suis
plus seul et je reste moi sans rien
changer
alors ça il faut le dire tout plaire ça
ne peut pas marcher
la rencontre est un art qui demande du
talent et du temps alors l'aide au coup
de foudre est devenu un service comme un
autre c'est un marché en plus mais
beaucoup de magie en moins